Фашизм не пройдет!
Беларусь!
За батьку!
Хто ці люди, які вийшли на вулицю підтримати Олександра Лукашенка
і вважають його легітимним президентом країни?
Чому вони мітингують "за бацьку"?
Мені 26 років. Стільки ж в нас і президент.
Я за 26 років нічого поганого не відчула від нього.
І тому я проголосувала за Лукашенка і загалом я вважаю,
що в нас 97 відсотків кажуть начебто за Тихановську,
але насправді це ми, 97 відсотків, за Лукашенка.
Ми прийшли сюди його підтримати.
У Білорусі немає незалежної соціології та об'єктивних соцдосліджень.
Тож точно визначити, хто саме підтримує "бацьку" складно.
Традиційно "ядерний електорат" Лукашенка становлять чиновники, силовики таїхні родини.
А також люди старшого віку і певна частина бюджетників.
На думку політологів, від двох останніх категорій
останнім часом дедалі менше підтримки.
Друга світова закінчилася 75 років тому,
і ветеранів залишилося вже дуже мало.
А те, що дедалі менше бюджетників і робітників у групі підтримки Лукашенка,
пов'язано з низьким доходом людей і розчаруванням.
За оцінками оглядачів, реальна підтримка "бацьки"
давно не відповідає тим даним,
які озвучує білоруська влада і може становити лише 20%.
Вибори пройшли чесно.
Якби хтось інший, я би погодилась.
Але ж там було зрозуміло,
що Тихановська не проходить.
Там почитати її програму й одразу ясно.
Тільки він наш президент.
У соціальних мережах та пресі було багато повідомлень,
що людей спонукають приходити на офіційні мітинги
і навіть масово звозять до Мінська з регіонів.
В основному бюджетників, яких змушують підтримувати Лукашенка.
Самі ж учасники акції підтримки запевняють, що ніхто їх не примушував,
і в один голос стверджують, що прийшли "за покликом серця".
Тільки поклик свого серця і своєї душі.
Тільки це.
Головне, що привело - поклик серця.
Ми за мирну і квітучу Білорусь,
і ми прийшли сюди
під своїм державним прапором.
Більшість учасників мітингу відмовлялися говорити з Deutsche Welle,
пояснюючи, що коментарі дають лише білоруським державним ЗМІ.
А відповіді тих, хто все ж погодився пояснити,
чому прийшов на мітинг за Лукашенка, були дуже схожі.
Люди в один голос казали, що вони за мирну та безпечну Білорусь.
Ми прийшли, щоб зберігся мир у нашій державі,
щоб не було отих людей, які ходять з фашистськими прапорами по Білорусі
і громлять тут все
26 років живемо добре, чому б і далі так не жити. Всього вистачає.
Одяг, хліб,  все є. – Ось за це і прийшли,
без війни, щоб не було такого, що було пару днів тому.
Це найголовніше.
Тому що я хочу жити в цій країні.
Нехай ми і не дуже багато живемо,
але ми живемо самі, як вважаємо за потрібне
А якщо прийдуть наші опоненти, то буде Україна, філіалом України.
Чимало прихильників Лукашенка повторюють тезу,
що Білорусі загрожує якийсь уявний ворог,
країну треба захистити і зробити це можна лише з "бацькам".
Я сюди прийшов, тому що мені прикро за мою батьківщину,
яку хочуть у мене відібрати.
І ми цю батьківщину нікому не віддамо. Тому ми тут.
Хотів би побажати Олександру Григоровичу здоров’я,
залізного такого, міцного, і щоб ще не одну п’ятирічку
він радував нас на посту президента, піклувався про нас.
Наша рідна країна може нагодувати теплим хлібом,
напоїти джерельною водою, але одне вона не може.
Вона не може захистити сама себе.
Ми захистимо Білорусь.
І давайте ми разом, ми білоруси, наведемо порядок у себе в голові:
за мир, за Білорусь, за нас.
Прихильники Лукашенка незадоволені акціями протесту
проти фальсифікації голосування та за проведення нових чесних виборів
і називають це  "заворушеннями і свавіллям", "втручанням Заходу".
Вони забули, що відбувається у сусідніх країнах,
особливо останні 30 років, яка іде експансія Заходу.
Ми начебто і не проти Заходу, але ми не хочемо, щоб вони до нас втручалися.
У нас свій шлях - білоруський, добрий, чесний, робочий, працьовитий.
І ми не хочемо, щоб хтось йшов до нас зі своїми пропозиціями,
які нам не потрібні.
Деякі учасники мітингу пояснювали свою участь
у провладній акції доволі оригінально.
Прийшов Лукашенко, перший його указ був:
за невиплату зарплати - в тюрму. Одразу ж з’явилися гроші.
От за це я його поважаю і тепер підтримую.
Сам же "бацька" тим часом відвідує підприємства
і спілкується на камеру з робітницями,
які показово виголошують йому слова підтримки.
- Ви знаєте, ми зараз так хвилюємося за долю нашої батьківщини.
- Даремно.
- Ми переживаємо, бо знаємо, що ви наш президент.
Тому ми з вами і ми за вас. І ми усім колективом
вам бажаємо сил, здоров’я і ми переможемо
- Ви навіть у цьому і не сумнівайтесь.
На одному з останніх мітингів виступали артисти білоруської естради,
а також був організований відкритий мікрофон.
Серед бажаючих висловитися ніби випадково виявився
і колишній командир білоруського СОБР Дмитро Павличенко,
якого підозрюють у причетності до політичних убивств
опонентів Лукашенка наприкінці дев'яностих.
За словами ексбійця СОБР Юрія Гаравського,
саме Павличенко вбивав ексглаву МВС Юрія Захаренка
та ексглаву Центрвиборчкому Віктора Гончара.
Павличенко похвалив дії силовиків під час розгону демонстрантів
одразу після виборів.
У цьому він і сам брав участь.
Три доби ми стояли разом з ветеранами, разом зі спецназом і ОМОНом.
І розгромили їх на голову.
Не дамо ж далі просуванню цих екстремістських ідей, екстремістських цілей.
За батьку, за Білорусь!
Мітинг тривав трохи більше години. Наприкінці акції люди заспівали гімн,
підглядаючи текст у телефоні і на аркушах, а потім швидко розійшлися.
А на іншій акції деякі учасники ще потанцювали з написом "Ганьба зрадникам!"
А також поскандували, щоб люди працювали, а не протестували.